[Music]
how do you get
information from someone who wants to
keep it from you
somewhere locked inside their brain
could be the truth about a crime
or the plan for a terrorist attack or
the password to a bank account or
nuclear codes to get information we
often resort to violence
but that often doesn't work and can
cause a person to close off
even more but that's not to say there
aren't other ways of getting people to
talk
or even of getting their brains to talk
for them in this episode i'm going to be
injected with a truth serum
i'm going to coerce people into giving
false confessions
and i'm going to try to hide the truth
from a
mind reading machine what's the best way
to get the truth
or detect a lie let's see if anybody can
dig out the secrets i've got locked up
in my head
[Music]
it's a classic scene in spy movies
someone captures someone they want
information from
they inject them with truth serum and
the person spills
all their secrets the serum used in
almost all of these movies
is sodium pentathol which is an actual
drug that inhibits brain activity
it was first used as a painkiller but
was found to work better as an
anti-anxiety drug
it dulls your thoughts making it harder
to perform cognitive tasks
including the task of making up a lie
the use of truth serums began in 1915
when dr robert house a physician in
texas realized that scopolamine a drug
given to women during childbirth
had the effect of getting them to talk
without reservation
another drug midazolam has been used to
treat iraq war burn victims who suffer
from ptsd
midazolam helps reduce their inhibitions
allowing them to talk more freely about
their experiences
midazolam is also one of the drugs used
in lethal injections
including several botched
i arranged to be injected with midazolam
to see if it could make me spill my guts
[Music]
this is the midazolam the medicine we
are
going to use this is enough to put an
elephant to sleep
so we'll have to make it very very very
dilute and then give you very very small
amount of the delicious please
yes you would be comfortable and happy
it's euphoric it will feel very cool
but i also want to keep some secrets
that is to remain to be determined
okay michael i'm will introduce you to
dr bevlong
hi nice to meet you how are you doing
good
dr pavlov is a police psychologist and
an expert in interrogation
have you started the drip yet uh we
would like to start
with the amount of one milligram
dr pavlo's objective was to get me to
admit to certain information
one that my sister's name is melissa and
two that my job is hosting minefield and
vsauce
my objective not to admit the truth
are you feeling more relaxed in your
body i'm feeling warm
all over it's amazing how quickly this
came into effect
let me just ask you a couple of basic
questions i'd love to okay
where are you what town what's the city
how old are you 31. do you have any
siblings
yeah how old is your sister melissa
uh that that's not her name
um what do you do for a living i am a
choreographer by
trade what might be something i'm
familiar with that you did
have you heard of um the lion king
yes on broadway i have i think he needs
an extra dose
absolutely that means i got it right
they are
too sharp how much have i had total so
far
two milligrams
question for you how do you feel now i
feel like in order to feel like this i
would have had to have had
six drinks tell me about minefield
minefield yeah
my minefield
uh they're they're terrible they're
places that we've got mines
still littered throughout the in the
land cambodia vietnam
you know i think you misinterpreted my
question youtube
show minefield that you host tell me
about that scientific i am somewhat
familiar with it
did he get another dose okay we're just
going to get you even
more relaxed
tell me your occupation i'm a
choreographer
and siblings i have a sibling in uh
colorado
what's your favorite food uh rotisserie
uh greek donner does her sister melissa
like that too
she'll eat the meat by itself
trying to get michael to admit that he
has assisted melissa was no easy feat
luckily he was anesthetized enough and
did admit that he had a sister melissa
you ever think about being an uncle
or a father yourself do you want
children oh i would love to
have children yeah my my wife and i are
trying
but i'm always doing stuff like this
you know yeah it's like hey honey do you
want to make a little
baby and i'm like i gotta go
get interrogated and pumped full of
midazolam are you gonna give him any
more yeah
because i he's not sedated enough
i could do another one this would
probably be the last i wanna give
yes do most people at this dose fall
asleep
oh yeah
how you doing michael
go ahead feeling a little bit more tired
now yeah
and heavy who's the president
president pt president trump president
trump where are we what city are we in
yo pasadena which show do you like to do
more
minefield or vsauce which one do you
enjoy
more
vsauce yeah why
because they can be whatever i want them
to be and there's no executive in
control
by the way my eyes were closed weren't
they
and i didn't realize that you were still
a real person asking me questions
i think had it not have been for the
drug
there's no way he would have admitted
anything before you were pretending to
be a choreographer weren't you
no it's the drugs but i really am a
choreographer
after a few minutes he got right back on
track he's
very strong-willed and really believes
in what he's doing
and was able to maintain the charade
okay you're done
how do you feel uh
oh i feel ready to drive
just kidding while midazolam lowered my
inhibitions
and my ability to lie consistently truth
serums raise ethical concerns
about one's right against
self-incrimination furthermore
large-scale studies have shown that
truth serums can cause people to
reconstruct and fabricate memories
so truth serums are not very reliable
but what about the techniques used by
the police
[Music]
i'm going to tear you apart if you don't
give us some answers michael let me take
a shot at this
look we're all friends here
if i was in your shoes i'd probably do
the same thing you're being too easy on
this scum
your fingerprints are all over the crime
scene
you make me sick michael if you get them
too
scared they'll shut down we only want to
scare him enough
that's right and after i do that he's
going to give you relief
and then we'll do that over and over and
over again you're going to be taken on
an emotional roller coaster that will
deplete the finite cognitive resources
you'll need to keep withholding
information
all right i confess it really does work
you see at one moment i'm terrified but
then i'm comforted
the constant shifting from one emotion
to another fogs my critical thinking
until i might confess to a crime
i didn't even commit it's called the
fear
then relief response
the good cop bad cop method of
interrogation evolved out of a
psychological manipulation procedure
called
the reed technique developed in the
1950s
and used broadly by police departments
since the 1970s
now under the reed technique
interrogators first
assess whether a suspect is withholding
the truth
if they think the suspect is lying
interrogators then move
to the second stage in which they seek a
confession
now critics of the reed technique say
that the first phase
isn't reliable enough and that often
someone who is completely innocent
makes it to the second stage where it's
assumed they're guilty and police begin
seeking a confession and they often get
it
but why would anyone falsely confess
well to find out i decided to learn how
to make someone
confess to a crime they didn't commit
dr melissa roussano is an expert in
investigative research
including the process of interrogation
and confession
tell me about false confessions and why
people make them
in a nutshell people confess to crimes
that they didn't commit because
they come to believe that it's in their
best interest to falsely confess and
that's really counterintuitive right
because
confessing is the worst thing to do
right like that's what you need to avoid
at all costs
yes when you're not in the situation of
being convinced that it's actually your
best option
but that's kind of what i want to do
today i want to see how easy it is to
get a false confession from someone
how do i do that one way is minimization
techniques
you've got to get them to believe that
their best option out of this situation
to make this
end is to confess you can say look i
really think it's in your best interest
to cooperate
there are other techniques as well like
maximization right okay so they have to
believe that if they don't confess
things are going to be worse
um that the punishment will likely be
more severe and so their best option
in the moment is to is to confess to you
one
other technique is befriending them
where you're lulling the suspect into a
false sense of security
to trust you now what about making a
deal so
police officers are not allowed to make
explicit offers or leniency or
or a deal so you cannot make any
promises
but you can say look i really think it's
in your best interest to cooperate
you don't have to explicitly say
something for the message to be
communicated
with all these tools in mind i was ready
to try to get a false confession
all right our subjects answered our
online ad
offering 75 to test a new logic exam for
an educational institution
they didn't realize that the institution
was fake and the other participants
taking the test
were actually actors working for us it's
a pretty standard
release form before the test
participants signed a document stating
that they would be under breach of
contract
if they cheated on the test when you
work on the individual questions it's
very important that you work alone don't
talk about what you're doing
don't share answers good luck see you
soon
the subjects didn't know that there were
several hidden cameras around
and that we were watching everything
unfold from another room
during the testing the participants and
our actors did not
share information at no time did
cheating take place
i'm going to collect these and put them
in the database and i'll be right back
to start the next phase okay guys
thank you thank you i wore an earpiece
so that melissa could guide me during
the entire process
a few minutes later it was time to set
up a false accusation
so we actually might have a problem um
i'll need to speak to each of you
separately
so james could you come with me just
outside i'll take these now thank you
and um nicole you can just wait right
here awesome thank you
you gotta give him enough time to
plausibly be talking to
and calling the director
hi nicole hello you and james
both had the same wrong answer for the
triangle problem
it looks to me like there was
information sharing like you guys spoke
to one another about the answer on that
problem but we didn't talk about it
during the individual
problems i kept my eyes on my paper
because i knew that would probably throw
off the
results if i look if i just write out
here like
i admit that i
shared answers i don't remember
talking to him at all about like what
we're doing first i tried to minimize
the consequences of confessing
i really think it's in your best
interest i really think it's in your
best interest
to sign this stating that you admit to
sharing the information
i honestly believe that that is but i
did not
look i i don't know what's going on here
i really that's i don't know i came here
to help i understand
and i never said like hey there's megan
please let me finish because i i don't
appreciate like over talking and stuff
i was too aggressive at first i had a
lot to learn
next i tried to maximize the
consequences of not confessing
what we're looking at is is possible
breach of contract here
if he comes down here he's going to be a
lot more upset
if the director has to come down here
he's going to be even more upset and
annoyed than he already is
it did not happen okay and i i put that
on my dad and i went down around my neck
so once it was me against her family i
lost my chance to get a false confession
i had to become the suspect's friend i
also understand
you're a nice guy and like sharing
information or helping someone with the
problem
is the nice thing to do it's what we
normally do but i didn't share the
information
so i can't sign that document but i
failed to convince this guy to be my
friend
i struck out with all these test
subjects but after my failed attempts
i was ready to put everything i'd
learned into my next encounter
is there a strategy i should use i think
that you should proceed
with making sure that you're not overly
confrontational and
making sure that she sees you as someone
who she can trust your advice and so i
would i would proceed with that kind of
approach
okay going in
thanks for waiting so
i think we do have a problem i was
looking through your
individual questionnaires and you guys
both
had the same wrong answer
on the triangle problem really so it was
kind of this weird like okay
what's going on like statistically what
are the chances that two people are
going to have
these very unique answers
so i called the project director to see
what to do
because if you know this is a sign that
information was shared during the
individual section
that's a major problem for the study
right yeah look at each other's stuff
that was like we were like on
like we didn't ask each other anything
we didn't like
you know we didn't talk to each other
the whole entire time and so i don't
know how we got the same answer
but i'm like 100 sure that that was like
the answer that i came up with
deja was resolute about her innocence
but i was about to maximize the
consequences of cheating
should she not cooperate and that's a
really big deal because
through this grant we need to have the
integrity of the data we need to always
obey the rules of the experiment
and it could even be a breach of the
contract that you guys signed when you
came to do this
study okay dejan now knew what was at
stake
my job was to convince her that i had
her best interest at heart
i have to call the director back right
and i can either tell him
i don't know what's going on we can't
proceed like you need to come down here
i don't know who he's going to involve
the easier shane was involved though
all i know is that i can't explain what
happened okay
the easier option is to just document
that
um information was shared okay so
if i write out um you know i
admit that i
shared uh the answer
is that crazy to say that we didn't
share answers though
because i'm like i don't know what he's
saying or if he said
that he looked at my answer or but we
didn't
deja wasn't quite convinced so the next
tactic was to minimize the impact of
confessing
i don't know exactly how it happened i
just know that we've got to figure out
the best way forward this is so weird i
don't know exactly how it happened
it looks like information sharing if you
just tell us that that happened
then what we can do is i can call the
director back and say that you guys are
cooperating
and i know him that's the best thing
okay i mean it's not true but outside
okay if you sign and date it i can go
and call him back
and i'll try to get you out of here
thank you very much deja i will be i'll
be right back thanks for your patience
so you did an excellent job of
communicating to her that it was in her
best interest at the best way out of
this situation was to confess
but it feels so bad i mean she knows the
seriousness
she knows that it's a lie
i mean i didn't cheat this is not cheap
those were all my answers
[Music]
hi okay
uh this concludes the study i'm gonna
give you a debrief now
uh to tell you about what we're studying
so
first of all you're not in trouble
the other guy here works for us this is
not a study of logic problems it's a
study of
interrogation and false confessions
you falsely confessed today i see that
how do you i feel mad at myself
because i'm usually the one who like you
know
just sticks to what
you know is right i tried to at least so
what happened today
it was just scary i guess because it's
an environment i've never been in
before and then just like all the
pressure
it was just like oh well i guess
i should just sign it and say that i did
it
despite knowing she was innocent and
knowing that she was admitting to
breaching a contract
deja signed a confession that in a true
criminal case
could be used as evidence in a trial
against her
imagine if there were consequences and
this
was a real crime how easy it is to get
someone to confess to something
without even punching them or
waterboarding them just being nice and
telling them that it's in their best
interest
yeah it's messed up actually isn't it
it's really crazy
because there's a lot of people in
prison for
crimes they didn't do
the innocence project an organization
dedicated to uncovering miscarriages of
justice
estimates that 20 000 people are
currently falsely imprisoned
in the u.s the number one cause is
faulty eyewitness testimony
and the number two cause false
confession
current interrogation techniques are
unreliable they can
fail to produce truthful information
from suspects who are good at lying
and perhaps worse they can manipulate
innocent suspects to confess to crimes
they've never committed
but neuroscientists may have discovered
a method for extracting the truth that's
impervious to good liars
and bad interrogators
dr peter rosenfeld and his team at
northwestern university
including phd candidate ann ward have
developed a high tech method for lie
detection
but you guys brought with you today a p
300 based concealed information test
how does that work and how is it
different than a polygraph or
traditional
verbal only interrogation techniques
well we're looking
at physiological responses of the brain
in response to information that's
presented and if the information is
meaningful
like the murder weapon that a guilty
person used he will recognize it and
there's a brain signature to it
and so the machine that we brought with
us is basically an eeg machine
so the way my brain your brain all of
our brains respond to things that are
meaningful that we recognize
is different than the way it responds to
novel meaningless things
right has this been used in a court
has it been used by a prosecution not in
court
there are some fifth amendment issues as
far as betraying
yourself based on your brain waves but
you could use it for witnesses
or you could use it within companies
that are already using polygraph methods
okay well i'm excited to see this in
action i'm gonna step
out you guys are gonna prepare the first
test okay
excellent all right see you soon
okay we're ready for the test
thank you for joining me hannah from
vsauce wren from corridor digital
so one of us today is going to be a
thief per dr rosenfeld's instructions
we randomly determined who would be the
thief by seeing whoever drew the green
chip
three two one
hannah's the thief oh my god i knew it
so hannah
go on in look at the item
in this real world scenario designed by
dr rosenfeld
the designated thief actually takes the
item handles it
and gets a good look at it this activity
causes the item to register
in their mind so they can't help but
recognize it later
the other subjects are also required to
enter the room
and sign in to prove that they were
there but they never get a look at the
stolen item
and of course dr rosenfeld and anne have
no idea who the thief is
then each of us is tested i'm going to
take a seat here and we'll get you all
set up
basically i'm just going to put a couple
electrodes behind your ears and a couple
on your face
and then the eeg cap on your head what
you're going to do is you're going to
use these two
mice in front of you to respond to the
images that you see on the screen
so you'll see an image a string of
numbers an image's string of numbers
anytime you see an image no matter what
it is you're going to press this button
all right are you ready
the images we were shown contained a
variety of jewelry items
including the stolen one of course ran
and i hadn't seen any of them before
hannah didn't consciously react to any
of them
but would her brainwaves reveal the one
item she recognized
it was time for the results
so here we are have you reached a
conclusion
well based on what we know and we know
that the stolen item was a watch
and so we looked at the brain waves in
response to the watch in comparison to
the brain waves in response to other
things
and we have two average
brain waves or event related potentials
in each frame the black one is the
average
brainwave response to the watch the red
trace there is the response to the
other stimuli all average together we
look for the peak to peak difference the
peak down here versus the highest peak
following this peak
and we measure that and it's rather
obvious that
the biggest response we found was
hannah's wow
an interesting thing michael is that you
had
a special response to the watch in
comparison to the other items
that would suggest that there's
something special about
that stimulus the watch that that is
meaningful to you
is it i collect watches i have about
40 or 50 of them but hannah might not
have that kind of experience i don't
have that many watches
and out of the three of you she
definitely has the biggest response so
off to jail
the p300 concealed information test
correctly identified which one of us
was a thief but in this next test i will
be the only suspect
and they will know that i've stolen
something but the question will be
what did i steal inside this room are
seven boxes and inside those boxes are
seven
different items that i've never seen my
task is to open only one box at random
and steal that item
alright we've got a a camouflage hat
and that's not all during this next test
i will be implementing
counter measures to try to outsmart the
test i will think
a very strong thought every time
something comes up that's irrelevant
will that enable me to create brain
waves powerful
and dramatic enough to not be
distinguishable from my response
to the actual item i'm trying to conceal
anne hello welcome back i uh committed a
crime
wish me luck because this time there
will be
punishments like in the real world where
getting caught in a lie
can have consequences and my friend adam
savage was
happy to advise me on my punishment adam
michael i am going to be taking an eeg
lie detection test okay if
i lose there need to be stakes okay yeah
yeah yeah
naturally i thought of chinese water
torture which as you know from personal
experience is when someone is restrained
while water is dripped
on their forehead and then right after
that i thought i know just the guy to
talk to about this okay
because i i want it to be actually
something that i'm fearing
and dreading so yeah we did an episode
on
chinese water torture on mythbusters and
the creepiest thing that happened
after we did this episode
was that i got an email from someone
from a throwaway account
he said we found that randomizing when
the drops
occurred was incredibly effective that
anything that happens on a regular
periodicity can become a type of
meditation and you can then tune it out
if you couldn't predict it
he said we found we were able to induce
a psychotic break within 20 hours
it sounds like the stakes that i want
all right
thanks you're welcome sir so now
under the threat of chinese water
torture i was extra motivated to beat
the lie detector
all right that is it
i was trying to think about all kinds of
frightening scenarios i was trying to
tense up make sure i was really
uncomfortable the way i was sitting
well for most tests that would work but
we will take a look at this data and see
yesterday
wow okay i don't think they're going to
be able to figure out
what item i stole i
really kept my mind active i was going
crazy with countermeasures i was sitting
uncomfortably i was thinking about all
kinds of really
crazy things i was thinking about like
what if i have diarrhea right now
how would that feel how do i hold it
back and maybe i do have diarrhea
all these things that were sort of
physical in nature as well i thought a
lot about death and dying and being
dismembered
and if they can get it right i would
probably blame witchcraft as well as
science
well i would say that's it yeah okay
we're ready to give him our best guess
hello
hi hey you guys ready yep let me ask you
this
first of all how confident do you feel
pretty confident what did i take
camo hat camo hat camo hats yeah
that's impressive did you see any
evidence of countermeasures being used
not something i would swear to even
while i was doing the test i thought you
know what
i'm reacting too quickly to the actual
item i should also treat it as though
it's irrelevant i should treat them all
the same if you
are consistently reacting to all of the
irrelevance
with their specific countermeasure
responses that you formed in your mind
they should produce bigger p300s also
but the biggest will still be produced
by the ammo hat
even if you're countering it also and
that means
i now have to be punished
science is improving in its ability to
read people's minds
and that raises some difficult ethical
dilemmas
we would have nothing to fear from
perfect lie detectors
if the people using them had perfect
morals
so the prospect of a scientifically
rigorous method of extracting
information while exciting is also
terrifying as we continue to probe
interrogation methods scientifically
we have to also continue to probe them
ethically
you know chinese water torture isn't
even chinese
its earliest description comes from
italy in the 15th century
and the chinese name was added later to
make it sound more mysterious
oh man these irregular drops are
supposed to drive you slowly insane
you know i think this is a lot less
about getting information
and more about punishment and as always
thanks for watching
[Music]
so
you